庵野さん思ったんですけど前髪伸びるの早くないもう変でもないしそうと
思いたい初めてあ今日は外れ社長です皆さんぬいぐるみ好きですが僕はそんなに好きで
はありません今回はクマのぬいぐるみを買ってきましたこちら
はいこちら秘密のくまちゃんですすげーばトナーが受賞してるなぁすごい秘密のくま
ちゃんみんなが驚く不思議ぬいぐるみ
そうこれすごいいってはお友達になろうよって熊さんが入っております子供絶対に開け
てはダメですこれマジちょっとは俺マジかこれ
これでやばいな今見ている子供たち見ないでください
この中身はちょっと子供たちには見せられない
ないのでいうあの子供たちお父さんお母さんに今動画を見ていいか聞いてね聞いて
良かったら見てもいいけどお父さんをだったがダメって言ったらもう見ちゃダメだよ
だめで本当にこの中身だけはもう高校2教えられませんからございとか4歳の子供たち
は
見ちゃダメだ
どっちでもいいんだけどねただこの中身を知りたくない人は見ないでねアイデアいき
ますよ
はいこんにちわんこそだとペマさんがいるんですけどもうなんとこちらがすごいんです
これすごいいろんな改良金空いてるんですよくまなんでもしゃべるんですよ
もう隼人ハミ受けしてるとかなんでも言えるんですけどもここから本当に君と上れる
子どもたちだけ見てねはいこ
こちらトランシーバーでおかあさんが話しているんですねっ
クマがあたかもしゃべるようにしてちっちゃい子供たちだったらもうクマタンが本当に
喋ってると思って
ぱに本当にまずでしゃべれねえグルミットらしいば付でございましてあげていき
ましょう
どうした甘い可愛いなぁデコっちゃうトランシーバーでこれで僕はそれと孤独が
しゃべるとマイクに向かって話しかけます
っぽ系ああああっ
こんにちはうっっ
こんいちわ
こんにちは
動くんだねーまぁちょっと俺はつながってくれ
[音楽]
ん
n one
ありがとうございます1
しゃべれるんねすごくないこれマジでこれすごい済まず多分しゃべりばちゃんと
すごいなこれテレビで今回はこのシャベルクマタンを使ってピザを注文してみようと
思いますもうピザの配達の人もきっとでいつも同じピザの注文いつも同じ受け取り方
つまんないと思うよ
もっとこうロマンティックあふれる刺激的なピザの配達をしたいと思うのでお母さんの
家じゃ
タブって聞いただけでも多分みんな防衛しいると思うんだよ
俺なんかボイスに理由はちょっとねくなったんやピザを注文してみようと思います
たとえ不潔だぞ
先生とピザをと見たいんですけど
フォトン検討
のお届けでお願いします
便秘と生地のファイル10秒入ってる美術
はい大丈夫です
ユーモアしたでのキャンセルとかサイトジョブです
お気をつけてはいございます
何します
これめちゃくちゃ面白いなぁマジで愛的で今回はこの熊さんがピザを頼んで果たして
うまかっピザを取るとピザの発達してくれた鄭さんはどんな反応するのか試してみたい
と思いますで別途含む4
くまちゃんが入ってくまちゃんの人にはちゃんと
ピザを規模が準備してあります
[音楽]
前
ph
ありがとうございません
いいいいいい
ございまーうん
第じゃないはいそうです
続の人に骨があります
おん
ええええええ
[音楽]
を注いここでいいですかまあ
hey 青年を言ってるけわな
会津
ん
ああああああ
goo
[音楽]
me
ううっうぅうううぅ
car
me あっ
th
きます